bonsoir à toutes et à tous
on a tous un cerveau
en tout cas ce qui vous concerne en ce
qui me concerne ce soir j'ai même un
deuxième cerveau je pense qu'il va me
servir un petit peu pour pas perdre mon
fil rouge et vous allez comprendre tout
bientôt
que même deux cerveau c'est peut-être
pas encore suffisant
on a tous notre madeleine de Proust
cette vous connaissez peut-être cette
expression malin de Proust elle vient de
l'effet de souvenirs que ressent Marcel
Proust de son enfance heureuse que
provoquer l'odeur des madeleines
vous avez peut-être lu le livre Du côté
de chez Swann qu'il a écrit en 1913
ce phénomène d'une impression de
reminiscence ou de ressourvir et souvent
déclenchée par un élément de la vie
quotidienne un objet
un geste une odeur un son ou une couleur
qui réactive irrémédiablement un
souvenir à notre mémoire
pour moi
il y a ce son d'une rivière qui coule et
quand j'entends ce son quel que soit
l'endroit où je suis
c'est tout de suite chez ma grand-mère
du pas du côté de chez Swann du côté de
Glaris que je suis et je me souviens et
je du bonheur que je vivais là-bas d'une
grand-mère complètement dédiée à son
petit-fils
il y a des odeurs aussi
une des odeurs c'est l'odeur du figuier
et quand je sens l'odeur du figuier et
irrémédiablement quel mot compliqué
viens en moi le souvenir de vacances en
famille dans le sud de la France dans un
jardin ombragé ou le matin il y avait
pas mieux à faire que d'aller prendre
des figues et de les manger tel quel
on a tous des madeleines de Proust
quel est finalement la vôtre
la plus étonnante malaise de Proust à
moi est un geste
très souvent c'est un geste que je fais
assis
je prends et demain que je croise
et que je passe les pouces sous mon
menton
le regard au loin je bouge mes doigts
ainsi
essayer
juste pour voir ce que ça peut faire
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous voyez
peut-être
c'est inspiré
par un de mes enfants des saucisses
deviennent qui virent
plus poétiquement peut-être une nuée
d'oiseaux qui sont volent ou peut-être
vous y voyez mais rien
et ben moi
moi je vois un poulpe
donc cette madeleine de Proust sous
forme de gestes qu'on va appeler un
geste poulpeesque a donc un goût salé et
des gouttes finalement la plupart des
gens
le poulpe vrai c'est un être quand même
bizarre c'est gluant
ça s'appelle un céphalopode c'est
phaloto
et c'est vrai que ça sonne extrêmement
étrange et donc je parle bien du poulpe
le poulpe la pieuvre c'est la même chose
ou en anglais Octopus ou aussi connu
dans certains comptes finlandais du
Grand Nord le Kraken
donc ce geste pour le pince je me rends
compte que je le fais très souvent et il
me ramène chaque fois immédiatement en
enfance puis très souvent je me rends
compte qui me transporte mais beaucoup
plus loin encore
alors j'ai envie de partager avec vous
les raisons de cette fascination et
expliquer ce que le poulpe a toujours
fait pour moi et surtout vous
transmettre ce qui peut faire pour vous
enfant j'adore la lecture on fait je
dévorer même les livres et il y a un
livre
un passage
dont je me souviendrai aussi toujours et
peut-être que vous l'avez deviné
Jules Verne 20 milieux sous la mer il y
a cette scène
où Nautilus se fait attaquer par 12
poulpe géante
et le héros va tenter de défendre son
bateau en coupant les
tentacules géants et en plantant son
harnais son sa harpe dans les coeurs
dans le premier coeur du poulpe et comme
ça ne suffit pas il le plant dans le
deuxième coeur du poulpe et comme c'est
toujours pas suffisant il le plan dans
le troisième coeur du poulpe
c'est vrai que
de ressentir un animal qui a 7
cette capacité de survie multipliée
c'est quelque chose qui m'a vraiment
fasciné
et je me suis rendu compte en
réfléchissant ce geste du poulpe ça me
fait penser à ce poulpe va milieu sous
les mers et ben il me fait penser encore
à quelque chose d'autre
connaissez-vous Squeezie
est une héroïne d'une série télévisée
d'animation américaine dont les 26
épisodes racontent toute la même
histoire c'est une gentille pieuvre rose
il y en a qui connaissent en direct
qui porte un petit chapeau de matelot et
qui vit dans un parc aquatique elle est
douée pour la musique elle s'est jouée
du saxophone elle voudrait faire
carrière dans show-business mais bon
mais la [ __ ] dans un parc aquatique donc
elle est temps de s'échapper et il y a
un gardien qui s'appelait winchley CROUS
moustache comme ça quand on a également
il fait un peu peur comme ça
à chaque fois et lors des 20 petits
épisodes
winchler rattrape Squeezie
personnellement mais j'étais révolté par
cette situation je voulais que Squeezie
dans le cou pour que enfin non pas ce
qu'il dit ah winchelet donc que je suis
tordre le cou pour que enfin Squeezie
puisse vivre sa pleine vie
revenir
ces deux anecdotes si je les mets en
commun il m'amène à penser que le poulpe
intègre ces deux oppositions d'un côté
de force et de l'autre côté de faiblesse
telle un miroir de notre condition
humaine
certains intellectuels disent même que
la pieuvre est un guide incomparable
pour explorer les profondeurs de
l'esprit et les mystères de l'univers
pas mal
mais bon revenons sur terre ou non
revenons plutôt sur mer et puis un
poulpe quelle idée quand même d'aimer
cette bestiole non à la base on aime
plutôt un ours on aime peut-être un
lapin en poney ils ont l'air gentil ils
ressemblent aux humains ils ont des
expressions mais un poulpe ça doit être
complètement débile comme animal non
et force est de et force et de constater
également que ce put n'a rien en commun
avec nous en tout cas non avec vous non
plus
pourtant le poulpe est un être vraiment
fascinant et doté de capacité incroyable
qui lui permet de survivre de puis très
longtemps
on les analysant bien on se rend compte
que ces mêmes capacités peuvent nous
être d'une grande aide dans la vie de
chacun bon vous voyez physiquement tout
d'abord 8 tentacules c'est
impressionnant
combien de fois je n'ai pas rêvé savoir
faire plusieurs choses en même temps et
là avec 8 tentacules
la première personne à qui ça me fait
penser c'est plutôt à mon épouse avec
nos cinq enfants savoir donner le
biberon préparé à manger
en langue géant et en plus
dire on marie où sont les clés la maison
on voyait que c'est déjà une
réincarnation presque du poulpe
et huit bras et ceux qui ceux qui
incroyable aussi huit bras c'est que
chacun des bras et doté d'un cerveau
pour lui-même
donc le poulpe à la capacité de piloter
de manière indépendante chaque tentacule
de manière comme un automate tout seul
et en plus il a un grand cerveau central
qui lui permet de coordonner le tout
donc au total
9 cerveaux
ça c'est vraiment impressionnant
donc
dans les moments d'agitation contre la
situation est difficile quand tout se
bouscule de notre tête dans notre vie
regardons-nous quoi
de petites jambes
de petits bras un petit cerveau
masculin dirons certains certaines
alors soyons humbles on n'a pas le
pouvoir des pieuvres alors laissons le
calme revenir pour que notre unique
cerveau s'en sorte dans les périodes où
c'est les où nous sont nous sentons très
limités et sans doute c'est exactement
dans ces moments
ici une fois de plus
et que je fais mon geste poulpek
en fait
on analyse bien
ce geste mais la garder le calme
puis il y a cette autre prouesse du pool
que vous connaissez certainement sa
capacité de changer de couleur je vais y
arriver mais d'abord je dois faire un
petit détour par mon nom vous avez
peut-être vu son invitation que je porte
ce joli nom de cam
en allemand ça veut dire peigne
ça va
en français mais les jeux de mots vous
les imaginez sont nombreux bon allez
pour le plaisir on va s'en faire un ou
deux Monsieur Madame ont une fille elle
s'appelle l'autre
très bien
où va le câble la nuit
à soutra
merci
et tiens regarde cet arbre comme il est
plein
c'est pour les mécanos un arbre à cames
et puis le plus simple évidemment vous
le connaissez tu as pas vu Léon
caméléon bien sûr on me l'a tellement
dit que la première fois que je me suis
mis à mon compte en tant qu'indépendant
je me suis appelé caméléon
graphiste qui sait s'adopter à vos défis
évidemment
donc mon activité actuelle principale
consiste à concevoir des stratégies
communication pour des marques des
entreprises des organisations donc de
m'immerger dans une thématique donc
comprendre les profondeurs et des mettre
des recommandations pour les aider à
séduire et convaincre cette approche
permettant ensuite de créer des liens
forts
qui est
identiques dans la métamorphose du camel
caméléon lorsqu'il change de couleur
pour lui et en fait nous on croit qui
change de couleur juste pour se cacher
mais en fait non le caméléon change de
couleur pour interagir accès avec ses
collègues avec ses congénères c'est
finalement un moyen de communication
sociale
exactement comme la pieuvre
qui peut changer sa couleur selon
l'environnement où elle se trouve pour
ce camoufler mais surtout elle peut
changer les motifs et les couleurs pour
communiquer avec d'autres pieuvres
et en même temps le cerveau va repousser
on appelle cela la capacité de
régénération ou l'autotomie
et c'est bien cette force de
régénération à laquelle j'ai fait appel
qu'on juste avant l'an 2000 on
entreprises précédentes a fait faillite
la pieuvre la force la pieuvre persuadée
que nous avons mon difficile même si on
a l'impression qu'on a été amputé de
quelque chose d'important dans sa vie on
est capable de remonter à la surface on
est capable de trouver à nous les forces
pour renaître
et venons-en à cette bizarrerie des
trois coeurs du poulpe
on y arrive salut
trois cœurs du pôle
un cœur principal qui commande la
circulation du sang dont la plupart de
ces organes
mais quand on a autant de tentacules
évidemment il n'en faut la puissance
pour faire passer le sang donc il a deux
coeurs secondaires qui sont attachés à
chaque branchie qui augmente la pression
sanguine pour garantir que le sang
circule dans les vaisseaux et qui
retourne au cœur
c'est le parallèle que j'aime faire pour
me motiver et inspirer mes
collaborateurs
mettre tout son cœur tout ce que l'on
fait mais malheureusement c'est pas
toujours suffisant
mettre tout sec tout ce qu'on fait et
cela demande une certaine abnégation une
certaine endurance ces deux valeurs sont
un peu comme les corps secondaire du
pool qui permettent de tenir la distance
et soutenir le cœur principal alors
quand c'est difficile
à contre le poulpe il sait qu'il faut y
mettre du cœur et bien penser à ces deux
corps ils vont vraiment vous aider à
aller jusqu'au bout des objectifs que
vous êtes fixés
voilà vous comprendrez maintenant ma
fascination pour le poulpe il a d'autres
pouvoirs tout aussi inspirant envoyer de
l'encre vous voyez l'eau mordre ses
proies pour les paralyser sentir la
lumière à travers ses membres être
souple pour se faufiler partout élaboré
des stratégies être bienveillant avec
ses congénères
j'admire la pieuvre au point que j'ai
appelé un de mes enfants du nom de
Squeezie non bien sûr quand même pas
mais le poulpe est devenu l'animal totem
de mon agence de communication et
j'espère qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui nous
aurons vous aurez non seulement un
regard différent sur elle mais aussi une
attitude au moins octuplée à affronter
toutes les situations de la vie
en tout cas
à chaque fois que je me retrouve dans
une situation difficile je m'assied vous
connaissez le truc je croise mes mains
je pose les pouces j'agite mes doigts et
à partir de là la force du pool peut
être avec moi alors du fond de mes
3/4 je vous souhaite d'avoir le bon
poulpe et surtout qu'il vous permet de
dépasser vous limite que la force du
poulpe soit avec vous